-I'm so happy you're here.
I always love seeing you.
We have a lot to get into.
A lot of good news for you.
But last time I saw you,
we both played --
Justin Timberlake
does the 8AM Tournament
for charity in Las Vegas.
-Yes.
-And it was really, really fun.
-Yeah, it's a blast.
-Yeah.
-It's a great, great time.
I mean...
-The winners were crowned,
and I don't know.
-I don't remember. Who won?
-Oh.
-Oh, yeah.
-Me and Justin Timberlake.
-The people whose name is on --
[ Laughter ]
The people whose name
is on the tournament.
-We won the tournament.
-I don't know. Shocking.
-What are you talking about?
-I don't know.
-We just happened to win.
-Guys --
"Hey, J.J., will you come play
in my golf tournament?"
"Yeah. Okay. It's gonna be
a great competition. Sure."
"I won. Congrats."
[ Laughter ]
"This is fun."
-Dude, we have fun.
We --
-You contributed a lot.
I mean, in --
by way of outfit,
by way of outfit, not golf.
Jimmy --
Guys, I have to --
Jimmy has the best outfits
at this event every single year.
I just have one problem
with them.
They are the hottest outfits --
like, temperature-wise.
Not -- Jimmy's a great,
great-looking man.
-Thank you for saying that.
-Great-looking man.
-But he's wearing full cotton
in Las Vegas in April.
-I always forget how hot
it is in Vegas, but here's you
next to me.
-Yes.
-I'm wearing, like -- Yeah.
-Sweat-wicking Polo.
-Yeah.
-What you wear to play golf.
-Jimmy's got a cardigan.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. I'm dressed
like the Golden Bachelor.
[ Laughter ]
I -- I forgot how hot
it is in Vegas.
And, you know,
but I don't even think about it
because we're always goofing off
and doing stuff
and just having fun.
I wanted to show --
Speaking of having fun,
this is a great picture
I have of you from --
from the tournament.
-Oh, God.
[ Laughs ]
-What, uh...?
[ Laughter ]
What was happening?
-Jimmy, I told my -- I told
my grandma to watch tonight.
Now I got a ass shot.
[ Laughter ]
-Did you --
Did you fall in the bunker?
-So, what happened...
[ Laughter ]
-So, what happened?
What happened?
-What had happened was,
my ball went in the bunker.
It was a scramble.
Obviously, we're not
going to use it.
So I went to retrieve my ball
from the bunker.
I just wanted to grab it.
I grabbed it and realized
there's no possible way for me
to get back out of the bunker.
So I tried to crawl backwards.
[ Laughter ]
-What?
-It didn't work.
[ Laughter ]
So, to my savior,
J.R. Smith came and grabbed me
and pulled me out.
-That's hilarious.
-I don't even know where in life
I was at that moment
when I was facedown
in a bunker in Las Vegas,
and J.R. Smith said,
"Hey, brother, just let me
give you a hand."
I was like, "All right."
-It was so fun.
-Yeah.
Since then, I gotta say,
congratulations.
You have a baby.
You have a 1-year-old baby.
-I do. Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Congratulations, bud.
What's it like?
What's he like?
-He's the best.
He's the best.
He's crawling
all over the place.
He's scratching my face,
which is a little tough,
but it's truly the biggest
joy in the entire world.
I mean, nobody can explain it.
Obviously,
parents tried to tell me
all the time what it's like
once you have a child.
But until you have it,
you just have no idea the joy
and the love and the happiness
that it brings, so...
We were reading your book
last week, so thank you.
Yes, we were,
we were reading your book.
-And he got to see you play,
too, right?
-He did.
Last weekend in Houston,
they did a great job
honoring me.
He got to watch me play.
We got to watch my brother play.
It was my mom's birthday.
It was a very,
very special weekend all around.
-How did that feel?
Look at --
Look at the crowd.
Everyone's got your number
and your name there.
I mean, they love you there,
buddy.
-So, when I first got drafted
to Houston,
on Draft Night,
they booed me.
They booed me hard.
Really hard.
-Really?
-They didn't want me.
So I looked at it
as a challenge,
and I looked at it as something
that I wanted
to prove them that I was worthy.
-Yeah.
-So, now, 12 years later,
to be able to leave the stadium
with that scene
was was pretty cool.
It was special.
-And it was Houston versus --
-Houston versus my brother.
So I was sitting in the suite
thinking, like,
"Okay.
Everybody's wearing my jersey.
My brother's on the other team.
He made a play.
Do I cheer? Do I...?
[ Laughter ]
I had no idea what to do.
-You don't want
to become a meme?
-Yeah, I have no idea.
-Like a zombie.
-And he's like...
-Yeah, like he's --
My brain broke.
I was in a blender.
I was in a --
I was in a blender, Jimmy.
I was literally
standing up there, like,
"I don't know what to do."
-Here's you and your brother
and the baby.
-Come on.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
-Is this the coolest thing?
This is the greatest.
-That's going to be in a very,
very large frame
in our house for a long time.
-Yeah.
Please tell your brother
I said hi, too.
-I will. Thank you.
-Now, can you explain this?
'Cause I go, "Oh, my God."
You were a great
host on "Saturday Night Live."
And you just got the knack.
You have the charm.
You just got it all.
People love you.
I go, "He's going to retire
when he does."
I don't even know
who you're going to retire.
But I go When he does,
he's going to do movies.
He's going to do something.
-I want your job.
I'm waiting.
[ Laughter ]
I'm waiting for your job.
-What are you talking about?
-I would really like to work
with Quest, the boys, the crowd.
I'd like to walk out to a
standing -- yeah.
Thank you.
See?
[ Theme music plays ]
-No, don't play it!
No, don't play it!
-Welcome to
"The J.J. Watt Tonight Show"!
-That's not what you --
-Not at all happening.
-No, I mean, you get to walk
out to a standing ovation
every single night.
You get to have this --
One of the things --
You ask about movies and TV.
The thing that's the truth
about it is,
I came from a sport where,
if you make a play,
if you get a sack,
there's this energy.
The crowd gets into it,
there's cheers.
There's something
about that adrenaline.
You do movies,
you crack a joke
or you say the perfect line,
and it is crickets.
I do not like that.
-You can't laugh
because it's a movie.
-Yeah, you can't, like --
your co-workers aren't laughing.
I like opening the curtain
and it's a loud
standing ovation.
So I don't know how much you pay
these people every night,
but I am --
I am a big,
big fan of this setting.
-Yeah, but you ended up doing
a move that I didn't see coming.
You own a soccer team.
-Yes, football.
You call it soccer, I might get
kicked out of England.
-Sorry. Football?
Yes, football.
-Football.
Was this --
Your wife, Obviously. -Is it?
She's a professional soccer --
football player.
Oh, geez. I'm screwed.
Don't send this across.
Don't send it!
-You just said it!
I didn't know --
You just said it, yeah.
-It's over.
-Yeah. So...?
-But, yeah. So we've wanted to
do this for a few years,
and we were trying to find
the right club,
and we found Burnley.
We went over there,
we visited the town.
It's a very small, hardworking
town with great people
that just live and die
with their club.
And we really,
really love Burnley.
-It's a great Burnley
is Premier.
Premier League.
-Premier League.
-Yes, Premier --
Premier League.
I'm learning all sorts
of pronunciations.
-Premier League.
-I have to drink tea now.
It's a whole thing.
-Yeah. Explain to me --
this is something the team does.
You brought me --
-I did.
-A treat.
-Yeah. So every game in Burnley,
we have a little thing
called a Benny & Hot.
So, back -- Long story,
but back during World War II,
the soldiers came
back to England,
and one of the things that
kept them warm in the trenches
was Benedictine and hot water.
They just put it together.
So now at Burnley,
at our matches, when it's cold
and we need something
to warm us up,
we drink Benedictine
and hot water.
So it's -- it's --
Jimmy, I don't know
if you're aware
of the term "acquired taste."
[ Laughter ]
-No, I --
-It's an acquired taste.
-It looks fantastic.
Look how --
-It's not, it's not,
no, it's not.
-This is gonna fantastic.
This is for Burnley.
-So, we say, "Up the clarets."
We have a big match tomorrow
against Chelsea.
-It is hot.
-So we say, "Up the Clarets."
-Up the Clarets.
-Cheers to Burnley.
-To Burnley.
♪♪
-[ Coughs, spits ]
[ Laughter ]
-It's -- It's so good.
It's so good.
You guys should all try it.
It's delicious.
-Oh, my God.
-I don't...
What does it taste like?
-Like -- Like, uh...
-Like a melted cough drop
or something?
-Yeah. That's dead on!
-It's like a licorice.
-It's like black licorice
and cough syrup.
-Whoo!
-It's just so good.
I just don't know
how it hasn't caught on
in the rest of the world.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, I just wanted to say,
you're my best friend.
-Yeah, it's great.
It's great.
-And you're the best friend
I ever had.
-Does this thing do karaoke?
-You're the best friend
I ever had.
-♪ Sweet Caroline ♪
-♪ Living in a lonely world ♪
J.J. Watt, everybody.
J.J. and I are doing
something fun after the break!
Stick around, everybody!